in Libya's Capital Tripoli these people
gathered to show their support for the
flood victims in the East their signs
read delna our hearts and prayers are
with you
the storm was more than the
infrastructure could handle it left
misery and destruction in its path so
many people have died and are missing I
lost family members every family has
lost someone it's a very difficult time
may God be with our country
says when he saw the pictures from
Eastern Libya he had to do something he
organized a small shipment of Aid on
Tuesday with some friends now he sends
convoys on a daily basis
people from across the country are
helping what happened was a tragedy but
maybe we can benefit from it people here
are sad about the disaster but also very
happy and excited about the unity
dozens of donation centers like this one
have been set up in Tripoli people give
what they can
along with the extensive destruction
across dharna the city's two dams burst
after heavy rainfall since a tidal wave
down the valley entire communities here
were Swept Away into the sea or buried
under the rubble
the recovery operation goes on with the
help of international search and rescue
teams Libya has two rival governments
both have allocated funds for emergency
response efforts and to rebuild
devastated areas
but there are fears if they can't
cooperate much needed assistance might
be delayed
[Music]
now is not the time for politics it's
not time to talk about which government
does what it's a humanitarian issue our
people were Swept Away into the sea many
are missing
libyans have seen years of conflict and
divisions but many are putting aside
differences to help their fellow
citizens there's been an outpouring of
support from across the country what
happened in eastern Libya has brought
together a previously divided people who
are now uniting in their grief and loss
they hope politicians can do the same
Malik trainer Al Jazeera Tripoli
well this is the challenge of getting
Aid into devastated areas storm Daniel
made landform 11th of September in
Libya's eastern coast causing flooding
and damage in several towns the city of
dunno is the worst affected Benghazi is
one of the main points of entry for
deliveries by Road only two roads into
dunna are usable and they involve a long
winding route through the mountains the
port has also been reopened for Aid
arriving by sea but once emergency
workers arrive in dhana they're met with
more obstacles five Bridges have
collapsed splitting the city further
hampering movements to the worst
affected zones
we can cross live to Tripoli and speak
to Al jazeera's Malik trainer Malik a
scene of huge Devastation that with a
threat of waterborne diseases now on the
horizon it seems
yeah that's absolutely right I mean
there are thousands of people still
missing uh believed to be in the sea or
under the rubble in the in the mud uh so
there are serious concerns of of
diseases uh coming out uh you know
earlier we started hearing that it is
possible that the Eastern government
will announce the complete evacuation of
the city of Darna to to stop civilians
volunteers from coming in and just to
allow uh you know rescue teams to
continue their work but uh you know this
is the problem that I mean there's two
governments right so so we try to we're
trying to talk to officials in the East
also here officials in the west are
coming out with their own statements so
you know this this who do we trust or
who do we talk to that's an issue but
we're trying to figure out the the
solution and people talking to the
people on the ground and the situation
is devastating there are fears of
diseases definitely you mentioned people
on the ground them and who is attempting
to coordinate this huge humanitarian
situation there
I mean at the moment it appears that
it's just chaotic it's just everyone
just showing up and doing whatever they
can to help uh look people in Libya are
are uniting uh to help those in need in
eastern Libya and there's a real feeling
of Brotherhood uh that that's that we
haven't seen it's reminiscent of the
revolution in 2011 and people are also
starting to feel uh you know that the
International Community is helping I
mean dozens of countries now are are
starting to show up you know you have
Qatar turkey the the UAE Egypt Italy
Spain Malta uh the various EU countries
I mean the kuwaitis the jordanians so
people are pouring in libyans are
feeling uh you know that that that
they're getting help from the
International Community libyans were
divided for years but the International
Community has also been divided when
when it comes to Libya so the hope is
that we can see a unified stance and
Libya Libya can finally unite and become
a stable country after this disaster
okay Malik trainer thanks very much
indeed for that update from Tripoli